你看了100倍数,好了3个账,但是装不到什么钱,为什么呢,因为怀财不运,运气不好,对吧
但是呢,我小子不财,中文人,但基本上我学的每一个支持,我都能把他做到什么财富,为啥呀,因为我监障,是因为我明白了一个道理,什么道理呢,支持本身是不值钱的
比如说你一个顾客来说,我来过来拍鱼,把你从那个说订文老来拍鱼,扔了做得上,是吧
对吧,人家顾客是不使人家做,人家吃的是做好的能体,觉得我富裕的问题的产品,人为这个买单,所以各位知道,支持是不值钱的,很多人说你胡说八道,对吧
你是中文人生,我是大学生,咱俩去镜片,对,谁给的钱多,你没搞明白这个事,人家买的是牛买的钱,是为你未来的时间腹肺,不是为支持肺,以来,女主任生,你是大学生
从这个情况来看,你的智商可能会高一点,对吧,丢不曉吧,你过来了,你走到这儿了,对不对,你智商可能高一点,所以我拼用你的可能就会更大一点
或者工资稍微更高一点,但人家并没有为你的知识腹肺,那你告诉我,他们那条知识腹肺了,他是为你的时间腹肺,是为你的牛买腹肺,知识腹肺什么,知识真的可以,所以各位知识是不值钱的,能够帮别人解决问题的产品,能解决我问题的,能解决我痛苦的那个产品那个解决方案之前
所以我们过去高孤了知识的作用,所以很多人大量到图女知识,但是有一个技能备,确实了,就是知识产品的画的能力,那我今天就为大家分享一个方法特别简单,就一个方法,他其实是分量过了,第一个部分,你看,这是知识,这个是解决用哭痛年的产品问题,困难的产品,中印都是解决方案,知识解决方案,然后产品,这是两次用线,我们先说第一次有些
这是一个重点方法,就是你平时学习的时候,你会发现马上就能够在背上财务,你直接变很难,但是你通过我这一步,变成在特别容易,就是你每次学习的时候,你不要广计那个知识的,那个就是原材料,我刚才说了嘛,原材料嘛,对不对,你要把它变成可用的东西,所以每次喜欢了以后,你把它变成卡片,一张知识卡,这个知卡里边应该至少包含三个有数,第一个就是什么,他解决什么问题,
解决什么问题,通点嘛,解决方案怎么做的。对,所以每一条知识的有什么知识,什么通点,什么问题,什么解决方案。这有什么用呢,你看,就是有一带有人有道问题,他现在有数就不一样,对吧,我的知识不一样,啊,这个问题,这个解决方。所以就还有人,你教我以前做资讯的我的正在这个钱,好多人就一提问题,问题还没提完呢,我是OK,我知道了,问题怎么也就。对吧,问题解决方案,大不了就变量不一样,
还并不一样,稍微换一些变量,这个问题就解决了,对吧,这就是知识数学的第一次越前,那麽,但是这种越前的话,有个问题,就是一次只能卖一份,那我们希望一个知识可以卖很多份,那他知识可以不断的服用,这是怎麽吧,就是第二次也先,不是,你有一个知识,你知道什么问题,什么解决方案,有这个知识好了,对,然后你在网上看到,这个人也问这个问题,哎呦这个人也问那个问题,哎呦这个人也问那个问题,哎呦这个人也问那个问题,
说问这个问题会有很多人买的,对吧,然后你再去查一下,未来可能,还会有多少人有这个问题,你就可以把这个解决方案,然后把它转化成产品,什么叫把问题解决,转化成产品,有时候啊,你脑子行,你不得行,你定他,然后你来我这,把,把,把我解决方案移动给你按摩一断给你导致,对吧,一个小时帮有的,搞定啊,付费,这个没有你对不对,但是你会发现,
每次都在我导致我还在上,有没有什么办法呢,对吧,你把它做上去把产品,我吃了,我用了,跑了,不需要你,对吧,我改革手法收到的一个机器,或者是那个产品里面,就解决了,对不对,这个时候这个产品就可以买多,买,买出很多,这是第2次,所以就要支持,是不值钱的,人们购买的,是能够解决它问题的那个,那个产品,所以你中间需要一个转体啊,所以各位,两次月前,
一个是支持原材料,然后到解决方案,然后再通解决方案,到产品,一对度,对吧,所以各位,好好思考一下,以后养成这个习惯,现在就开始做,想想你最近觉得这个支持,把它变成一整支持卡,听碰,对吧,什么支持,解决什么问题,怎么解决的,方法是什么,支持是原材料,产品是菜,定单来自优惑,